j'ai crié le festival de façon à pouvoir
revenir tous les ans du 1er mai au but
des mets haut du 8 mai à partir donc
d'un dépôt de gerbe au monument aux
morts jusqu'à une soirée festive donc la
nuit créole un certain nombre d'ateliers
de rencontres qui sont projections de
films qui sont des expositions un
certain nombre d'interventions dans les
universités mais aussi dans les lycées
est axé autour d'un travail collectif
avec les lycées et les collèges et nous
remise de prix à ceux qui participent à
ce travail dans les salons du préfet de
la région de lorraine
il faut savoir que la lorraine c'est
quand même un très très grand
département entre dans une région qui
regroupe la meurthe et moselle les
vosges la moselle et la champagne
ardenne c'est quand même très important
alors je crois que cette fondation
poursuit le travail de l'association est
et tout cela vise à être en lorraine une
vitrine des autres maires et des
collectivités territoriales
j'essaie de construire je fais c'est de
construire autrement dit j'essaie de ne
pas me perdre dans un quotidien
fastidieux et qui m'amènerait à ne pas
apporter je dirais un sentiment de
partage
c'est une des raisons pour laquelle j'ai
écrit le premier livre que la voix
d'aimé pas c'était mon initiation à
l'écriture j'apprenais à écrire le
dernier riffs créole et des rivaux
pâques c'est le travail d'un docteur un
critique littéraire sur un autre docteur
qui est celui le travail de dix on a
montré un peu comme il amène ses idées
comment ils les trouvent et comment ils
constituent ce thème porteur qu'il
appelle antillanité ou curiosité ou de
ce que vous voulez mais de manière
constructive
écrire pour moi c'est transmettre
quelque chose et mes écrits les
vingtaines traduisent toujours d'un
thème porteur d'une essence maintenant
l'homme que nous sommes l'homme
antillais
vers vers une réussite une réussite
sociale politique économique et
spirituelle bien évidemment